لم تكتفي طالبان بمنع الفتيات من دخول
الفصول الدراسيه فحسب بلقى الطالبان
القبضه على الناشط الافغنيا بارز في مجال
تعليم الفتيات الافغانيات
الامم المتحده طالبت طالبان بتوضيح سبب
احتجاز مطيع والذي ياتي اعتقاله وسط القبض
على عدد من النشاطات الذين كانوا يناضلون
من اجل تعليم المراه ويسال بالغ من العمر
30 عاما يسافر الى مناطق نائيه من
افغانستان لتحسين فرص حصول جميع الاطفال
على التعليم رغم تلقيه تهديدات كثيره
يدافع ويس الذي ينحدر من اقليم قندهار
جنوبي افغانستان منذ السنوات عن تعليم
الفتيات لاسيما في المناطق الريفيه
المحافظه
وانشا منظمه مسار القلم قائلا ان الخدمات
التعليميه لا تصل لكثير من الفتيات اللائي
يعيشن في الريف
تاكلت حقوق المراه تدريجيا منذ عوده
طالبان الى السلطه عام 2021 بعد الانسحاب
الامريكي من اغلاق المدارس والجامعات حتى
يتم خلقه بيئه مناسبه على حد قولهم الى
اعاقه اعمالهن عن طريق منعهن من العمل في
المنظمات غير الحكوميه المحليه والدوليه
باستثناء القطاع الصحي هذا ويتعرضنا
الافغانيات لقيود شديده بطرق اخرى ايضا
حيث اصدر الطالبان مرسوما يقضي بضروره
تغطيه النساء بطريقه تكشف عن اعينهم فقط
ويجب ان يرافقهن قريبا ذكر اذا كنا يسافرن
اكثر من 72 كيلومترا كما تم منع النساء من
دخول الحدائق وصلت الرياضيه رشا خياط
العربيه